chargé
quelqu'un est accro
je vous prononce maintenant et un couteau
vous et votre petite leçon psychotique Gangnam
aujourd'hui est un retour sur investissement
six livres de plutonium pur sont
assez puissants pour changer l'équilibre du
monde imaginez de quelles cinq tonnes vous
aurez besoin de plus d'hommes si vous vous attendez à
sortez d'ici vivant je suis de retour vous ne pouvez pas laisser
le contenu de ce coffre-fort tomber entre de
mauvaises mains quel est le plan suivre et le
trouver le tuer
comment avez-vous fait ça regardez-moi
je suis sûr qu'il est plus gros que sa voiture alors
quelque chose
Je pense que tu fais ouais
tu vas avoir besoin d'une nouvelle pièce